When it comes to computer algorithms and what again, let's pause our
right here and Define an algorithm. What is an algorithm?
It is a
sequence of instructions
for the computer
and these instructions can have
different variations. If you
look at the slide here, they can either be sequential where you
were instructing computer to do one thing after the next
in that order.
Or they can be selected.
You can program a computer or you can instruct the computer.
to do statements but
in the conditional way
so for example
Let's say the user types in a username and password.
If the username and password is correct, then perform
these set of operations or these set
of instructions. Otherwise perform those other instructions.
So I can be. All right. Let's log them in.
and welcome them and pull up their profile picture
and
their
website preferences
or we can redirect them to the registration
page and tell them what the registration process requires.
and well, that could be another set of
instructions
a third
type of algorithm could be in an iterative algorithm.
Well you where we where you repeat a statement again,
and again until some condition is
Satisfied so for example if you have a subscription.
On your app if you have a newsletter, for
example.
You can send all those.
all of your subscribers emails
until all until you've reached the last user.
And then you will not stop this emailing process until
you have reached the final customer.
Now of course complex algorithms will be a combination of
all of these three.
And there one of the problems you will encounter.
When you're working on out, you know complex algorithms
that have selectivity and iteration involved
in the mix.
You will end up with something and you may have heard of this before spaghetti code.
where it is, so
problematic
And so prone to breaking.
That you as the program wouldn't
even want to touch it.
But on one hand you're afraid
of touching it. So that doesn't break on the other hand. You don't feel confident that
I will work all the time and what you want to
be able to do or what you'd like to be able to do is to
reduce the complexity.
To maintain the capability of the algorithm but
also reduces complexity. So it's so that it is.
You know.
testable
and efficient you may
have heard of something called time and space complexity, right? You can have two
algorithms that did the two two that can
do the same thing, but one is far more efficient than the other
in fact.
the efficiency of that
the difference in efficiency can
Really?
Be more pronounced.
when
the data is larger or one more users are involved.
So, how do you how do you go about reducing a very
elaborate algorithm?
And make it more concise.
and efficient
well, if you knew if you if you are able to
recognize what parts of the algorithm could
be
collapsed
or to which part of the algorithm you can
apply
propositional calculus
then
you'll be able to do that. You will be able to write very effective.
and elaborate algorithms
if you have this mathematical Foundation
And it really doesn't take much to learn propositional calculus
and we'll maybe soon look at look at
a tutorial.
right